of the soyuz earlier this morning from
the baikonur cosmodrome in kazakhstan
that liftoff occurred at
3 55 a.m central time 4 55 a.m eastern
time
as anton shkaplerov the soyuz commander
russian actress yulia parisild and her
producer director klim shipenko went
skyward on the soyuz 2.1a booster a
flawless launch from the baikonur
cosmodrome as the vehicle arced out to
the northeast eight minutes and 46
seconds later
the
soyuz spacecraft
separated from the third and upper stage
of the soyuz booster
unfurled its solar arrays and
navigational antennas and began the two
orbit chase to catch up to the
international space station you're
looking at video of the
opening the unfurling of those arrays
that took place
less than nine minutes after launch
several hours later the soyuz arrived in
the vicinity of the international space
station it had been on automatic
approach to the complex before some
communications problems uh occurred
in the final uh stretch of the
rendezvous
anton shkaplerov the soyuz commander
took over manual control of the flying
of the soyuz which
then slowly but surely eased its way on
final approach for a link up to the
rassvet module again at 7 22 a.m central
time 8 22 a.m eastern time
the bottom line
was a successful docking
once the two vehicles had contact and
capture with one another the docking
probe on the soyuz retracted and hooks
on both sides of the docking interface
closed
around one another to form a hard mate
between the soyuz and the international
outpost
since then with the docking having
occurred about an hour and ten minutes
ago
the crew on board the soyuz shkaplerov
paracel and chapenko
have conducted leak checks on their side
of the docking interface
soon the small vestibule the small
passageway between the soyuz and the
rassvet module will be pressurized
and hatches will swing open shortly
after 9 a.m central time to enable the
three new
arrivals at the international space
station to enter into uh the rossviet
module in the russian segment
and they'll be joining their expedition
crewmates
led by the new station commander thomas
pasque of the european space agency
for a welcoming ceremony
and greetings
that will take place before they get
down to business the rest of the day's
activities today will include a safety
briefing that is common practice for all
new arrivals at the international space
station
before a familiarization a period for
shipenko and parisilde who are
space flight participants they're not
bona fide expedition crew members
they are space flight participants on
board for one specific reason and that
is 12 days of movie making for a movie
entitled challenge paris hill the
veteran russian actress and the first
actress to fly in space is going to
portray a surgeon launched to the
international space station to perform a
surgical procedure on a critically ill
crew member that will be played in the
movie by oleg novitskiy the veteran
russian cosmonaut who has been part of
the expedition 65 crew since his launch
from baikonur back in april with nasa
astronaut mark vande high and russian
cosmonaut piotr dubrov
chapenko and paracel
will again spend 12 days on board the
international space station they plan to
return to earth on the morning of
october 17th kazakhstan time on the
soyuz
spacecraft the one that arrived with
novitskiy vanda high and dubrov back in
april they'll be uh
coming home to a parachute assisted
landing on the step of kazakhstan on
october 17th
remaining on board the station will be
anton shkaplerov
the veteran russian cosmonaut who will
stay on board until the end of march of
next year with vanda high and dubrov who
will be coming home with some 355 days
in space since they were launched back
on april 9th of this year
[Music]
so the launch uh was flawless uh earlier
today the rendezvous and docking went
smoothly until the final minutes uh of
the final approach
when some of the communications problems
occurred
some of that attributed to bad weather
in guam
where the tracking and data relay
satellite system
maintains a relay capability to ground
stations
the tracking and data relay satellite
system had some dropouts there were some
issues
with the communications capability with
the core's automated rendezvous system
and as a result
shkaplerov was ordered by russian flight
controllers to default to a manual
approach he took over the hand
controller on board the soyuz vehicle
and manually flew the soyuz in for a
flawless docking to the rassvet module
on the space-facing side of the russian
segment of the international space
station
i'm performing the final adjustment oh
this is this is okay this is
[Applause]
after one minute i'm closing
[Music]
it is possible there will be a drop in
comb for 15 mm
[Applause]
[Music]
well maybe
i could
put it
back even more a little bit yes let's
try it
[Applause]
this view inside of the
russian segment of the international
space station
in the rassvet module
you're looking at the hatchway
behind which is the soyuz vehicle
there's a good view of russian cosmonaut
piotr dubrov
he's checking the camera angle and
the equipment
in that passageway
leading to the hatch of the soyuz
vehicle again on the other side of that
hatch
are russian cosmonaut anton shkaplerov
russian actress yulia parisild and
russian producer director klim shipenko
conducting leak checks
this will take a several more minutes
uh before uh pressure is equalized on
both sides of the docking interface that
will lead to the opening of the hatch
as needed
[Music]
[Applause]
will be about an hour
copy in an hour
[Applause]
this is mission control houston
and as you probably heard just a moment
ago one of the russian flight
controllers
informing the crew that hatch opening
might be an hour away
[Applause]
[Music]
yes i confirmed
careful with them i don't think there
were any snagging here
so with the docking occurring a few
minutes behind schedule and the crew
working methodically
through leak checks
on
the soyuz side of the docking interface
the estimate now is that hatch opening
will be about 35 minutes behind schedule
somewhere around 9 40
a.m central time 10 40 eastern time
we'll
stay with you
to bring you all the latest as we listen
in to the conversations on board the
international space station and the
soyuz ms-19 but again hatch opening
originally scheduled for 905 a.m central
10 05 a.m eastern time
now likely
about 35 minutes behind schedule
the pressure is still two millimeters
1643 is the time
[Music]
page 66 step 7.4
so
and now we'll have to watch it
for five minutes for the time
uh sort of cheat media 16 44.
the pressure is
the pressure
yeah you secure it here so that it
doesn't flow away flow away
that's cool
empty so
[Applause]
australia supermarket
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
volume
so what
is for me 7.6
mosca
[Music]
7.6
is the request
from
[Music]
timeline
go ahead on two for timeline
we're talking with our russian
colleagues and uh
that seemed to be um
a little bit behind on the timeline for
the hatch opening uh
the talking was a little bit late
so uh
i am opening with the blue pressure
monitoring valve cockpit
the guesstimate
official
command
to be
[Music]
uh happening i've got you could we uh
have somebody check the cables on the
note one camcorder
that's our next troubleshooting step
um
[Applause]
i will
deactivate it after one minute let's
perform
future
[Music]
continue to step 7.7 at page 68.
i'm opening
us
after three minutes
we come from
[Music]
open uh
she's not safe for the time 1657.
pressure
how cutting
[Music]
so
seven five five
this is mission control houston uh this
view of the international space station
flight control room here at mission
control houston
as uh flight controllers are in the
midst of a shift handover
working uh with their russian
counterparts half a world away at the
russian mission control center
in the town of karl yaff outside of
moscow
aboard the soyuz ms-19 spacecraft that
docked to the international space
station about an hour and forty minutes
ago
soyuz commander anton shkaplerov the
veteran russian cosmonaut now making his
fourth flight into space
russian actress yulia parisield and her
producer director klim shipenko
are in the process of conducting leak
checks
on their side of the docking interface
between the soyuz and the rossviet
module on the earth-facing side of the
russian segment of the international
space station
shkaplerov manually docked the soyuz to
rasviet at 7 22 a.m central time 8 22
a.m eastern time
taking over manual control of the flying
of the soyuz from the core's automated
rendezvous system due to some
communications issues that cropped up
during final approach nothing
significant shkaplerov was able to guide
the soyuz in to a smooth docking
after which the docking probe retracted
hooks on both sides of the docking
interface closed
and a hard mate was established the leak
checks are in fact continuing
we're about 35 minutes away from the
opening of the hatch
between the soyuz and the rassvet module
that will enable the three
new inhabitants of the international
space station to board the complex and
be greeted by the expedition 65 crew led
by
the new station commander thomas pasque
the pressure is holding uh stable it's
[Music]
so should i proceed to seven eight
steps
yes but after you're standing by for the
repress of the vestibule and it's going
to be ten minutes
you need to um
we mentioned a moment ago that thomas
pesquet of the european space agency
took over command of the international
space station yesterday
from japanese astronaut aki hoshide
let's turn the clock back about 24 hours
and take a look at that change of
command ceremony that took place on
board the international space station
making pesquet
the first frenchman to command the
international outpost
today we are gathered here for the
change of command ceremony
during the past five months
i had the honor and privilege to serve
as the
international space station commander
during these five months we had
in addition to all the experiments the
science that we did
we had uh
multiple successful evas
and uh
a lot of cargo vehicles come and going
and we had mel uh
a lot of maintenance and also upgrades
and
uh thank you all for working together
and making this uh team such a great
team uh with all these achievements
aleg pyotr
mark
shane megan
and thomas you guys are amazing
it couldn't be
a
happier
than uh being a
member of this team so thank you
and for the folks on the ground uh every
single one of you in houston huntsville
munich scuba and moscow
thank you for
your help your support your hard work
and dedication
and throughout all the agencies
supporting the international space
station program
we could not have done
such a great work
without you your help
and so it is my
honor
to
give
tomah pesquet
the key
to the international space station
and tomorrow you've been an
amazing crewmate
and
you're going to be a superb commander so
congratulations
thank you sir
all right thanks aki i think uh i think
the whole crew is going to join me to
thank you for everything you did during
those five months uh five months
increment expedition 65.
uh you've led us every day you know
always smiling always being positive
always being in a good mood and you've
clearly i think prioritize our common
goals
and well-being above
your own
and
i think you've lost a few hours of sleep
in the inner process
you have this uncanny ability to
whenever help is needed on the space
station you just materialize out of thin
air no matter where we are no matter
what we're doing but you always show up
and uh and always you know with such a
positive attitude that it uh rubbed us
rubbed off on us and sometimes diffuse
the frustration that can build up when
you're struggling with a difficult task
so
um thanks a lot for that so like you
said we've had a also a couple of
challenging operational situations
during expedition 65.
uh we went through them very safely so
you're no stranger to that
so thanks psyche so i have big shoes to
to feel you took a lot of pressure off
me by doing such a fantastic job that i
don't even have to think about doing
better than you because it's not humanly
possible
but yeah thanks for being an example and
uh an inspiration
um i want to say a few words about
everybody else on the on the team
because i've had the pleasure to serve
under shane as a commander of expedition
50 and of course on the on the crew
dragon uh oleg was my commander on the
soyuz last time i flew to space
uh mark and megan have had the
leadership positions within the national
office so
i've learned a lot from all of you guys
on the ground and up here every day so
i'm hugely thankful for that honestly
and uh i'm looking forward now that it's
my my turn to try to do a good job to
keep the mission safe
achieve our operational goals and come
back to our loved ones healthy and happy
so those are the those are the goals
um i want to say how proud i am as well
to represent my country up here um there
is no doubt in my mind that my
my uh career path
and my opportunities owe a great deal to
the the leading and active role that
france has always played in uh in
aerospace and in space exploration in
particular whether it be
in its own name since 1962 was kness
french space agency
first western european in space in 82
and lots of other flights
and of course within isa since the since
the very beginning
engineer
is active the sector special theory
lastly i want to say a few words about
the the ops team the training team
medical team and all the all the support
functions on the ground
because we're talking about the change
of command up here on the space station
but there's a lot of leadership
um within the flight control team
there's a lot of brain power obviously
on the ground and a lot of people work
really hard every day
for us to come up here and and do what
we do so uh i was thinking about it the
other day and you guys actually uh try
to keep us safe uh make us successful
and keep us happy um so it's kind of the
definition of what it is to to love
someone brotherly love fatherly love
to care enough so that you want people
to be safe successful and uh and happy
so it seems like you guys love us
and it might fit the cultural stereotype
but it's no surprise that the words of
love would come from a frenchman
from space i think we all love you back
so thank you for everything you're doing
so that was a lot of words
but i think we have work to do so
looking forward to be the commander of
all of you awesome individuals and i
think we can bring it in and do
expedition 65 on three
one two three expedition sixty-five
[Music]
station
munich on two for aki and
aki
i
think that i can
speak for everybody
when all communicators in
saying that it's been an honor working
with you these months and seeing your
leadership and
how you brought your team together
both on the ground and in space
so thank you very very much
it's been really an honor
and it is a privilege being your friend
and i'm going to see you on the ground
very soon we all see you will be happy
take good care see you soon thanks for
everything and that was uh monday's
change of command ceremony aboard the
international space station enabling
thomas pesquet
of the european space agency
to take over the reins of the command of
the international outpost from aki
hoshide
of the japan aerospace exploration
agency
while uh
you were in the process of watching that
we continue to listen and follow along
as
the soyuz ms-19 crew
anton shkaplerov russian actress julia
parishild and her producer director klim
shipenko
continue a methodical leak check on
their side of the
docking interface the hatchway between
the soyuz and the international space
station's rossviet module
we are expecting a hatch opening to be
somewhere in the neighborhood of about
30 minutes from now
as they work their way through the leak
checks making sure that pressure is
equalized on both sides of the docking
interface
so we'll stand by
we'll listen along as uh the crew
talks to the russian flight controllers
of the russian mission control center
outside of moscow
and stand by for the opening of the
hatches the greetings between the
expedition 65 crew and the newly arrived
soyuz crew
and a short welcoming ceremony
and you can open it here that's right
yeah be careful
you see how everything starts floating
if you're not careful
this is what you said i need a
friendship do you want this one no not i
don't want anything right now
open the hatches
and then
we can go about our business and like do
whatever we need to do um
five minutes are down and the pressure
is seven five
once you are ready um we wanted to
let you know on what steps you need to
perform to deactivate the vehicle are
you ready to write it write the
recommendations down
yes please stand by one
uh-huh
okay go ahead
i am
it's going to be orbital flight pages
25-38
and that's going to be step
four thanks for watching
page
[Music]
so is it just one step
are you trying to offer me juice
so worried that if i open the juice it's
going to
escape
and you can actually once we open the
hatches
you will be able to change and do
everything else
to get ready so don't worry just wait
for a little bit
and the pressure was 754 i remember
good girl
russian flight controllers talking to uh
russian actress yulia parisild aboard
the soyuz spacecraft
basically advising her and her crewmates
to take it methodically as they work to
equalize the pressure
uh everything going smoothly with that
procedure that will lead
to the pressurization of the vestibule
of the small passageway between the
soyuz and the rassvet module and the
opening of the hatch
to the international space station some
25 minutes from now
once that hatch is open and the crew has
an opportunity
to
conduct a welcoming ceremony
they'll move into a standard safety
briefing that is common practice for all
arriving crew members on board the
international outpost
paraceled and chapenko will waste no
time beginning to shoot scenes on board
in the russian segment of the station
part of the 12 days
of movie making that they intend to
perform in support of the movie
challenge that they're
shooting on board the international
space station
one needs to be changed to
three
papa one to papa three
[Music]
by one because i am digging through all
the books right now
hey i see that
and what did you say
one
cartridge you need to change it out with
fair cartridge three
copy
and where is p3 located do you have any
uh information as far as where it is
located
placebo
let us check and thank you in advance
moscow i'll be very grateful
while we are still looking for that for
the location of the
[Music]
from cartridge
to the soyuz
the
ventilation in the
modules needs to be set up this way so
you move a foot
okay so for the intramodular ventilation
um
with uh the vehicle and mrn1
is that right
yeah
are you ready to write it down i am
so it's zero zero seven one zero
three four zero zero zero
remember
seven one zero
[Music]
uh floated away and these are wipes
that's for trash guys
yeah that piece of information what
you're doing i am writing down the
updates from moscow
so what's the barcode one more time the
barcode is zero zero zero seven one
eighty
as in romeo
okay
that's a 42m which is an mrm one and it
needs to be moved to the orbital module
that is right so you move it to your
soyuz
understood
and then from there as well
you take bam
number 13 with a three ipaka mask
or did you say 13.
it's 19 1 9.
19 plus three per car gas mask
also from mrm1
okay
yes everything is from mrm1 and about
the cartridge
side is number three
[Music]
and they
should
they should be marked appropriately
there is set two three and five four
cartridges there
okay
and uh you want us to switch them out
right
so set one from
in the in from s.i needs to be taken out
and you need to install
three there
okay copy
[Music]
so you just take your flat suit from
there
foreign
[Music]
and
guys you need to perform the 15-minute
measurement
that's it
that's right seven five four
[Music]
please stand by one
you move it to um soyuz 748
okay standby
um
moving on to the next page
[Music]
so unit two does not need to be
installed
so in case of fire you deactivate the
ventilation in boil
all right so and you want us to
deactivate that manual is that correct
affirmative
that's episode all right i wrote it down
that's pretty much it for the
deactivation of the vehicle and you can
continue working for page 68.
let me check what we have at the
beginning uh so it's going to be step 4
on page 35.
uh-huh
okay
[Music]
in step four um
so 4.5
is the deactivation of gaia
and you don't want us to perform it
right
that is correct
okay
i copy all
[Music]
do you want me to stow it there
and there should be a little button on
the side
okay
and once uh you have changed out please
let us know
could you please check what's the mv
pressure currently
what's the current pressure
so 1728 and the precious 754 how copy
copy
this is mission control houston you're
continuing to hear conversations between
the crew on board the
soyuz ms-19
you hear their call sign being
referenced by russian flight controllers
through the interpreter is astray
that's basically estrellas
which is anton shkaplerov's soyuz call
sign they are making their way
methodically through the leak checks
pressure holding nicely
at the docking interface between the
soyuz and the rassvet module
of the international space station the
soyuz systems have now been deactivated
as the crew on board the soyuz uh is
edging ever so close
to the point where they will open the
hatch and be greeted by the expedition
65 crew
on board the international space station
for a short welcoming ceremony
earlier uh the soyuz crew after docking
at 7 22
a.m central time 8 22 a.m eastern time
received a congratulatory call from
dimitri rogozin the head of the russian
space agency ross cosmos
who along with the russian state
commission watched the docking from the
baikonur hotel at the launch site in
baikonur kazakhstan
one of the items uh that will be on tap
for
yuliya parisild the russian actress and
klim shipenko her producer director
will be to transfer their custom-made
soyuz seedliners from the soyuz ms-19
spacecraft over to the soyuz
ms-18 spacecraft that is currently
docked to the recently arrived nayuka
multi-purpose laboratory module
they will exchange soyuz seat liners
with mark vandehei
and piotr dubrov
oleg novitskiy
who will command
the soyuz ms-18 back to earth with
paracelled
and shipenko his seedliner is in place
in the center seat of the soyuz ms-18s
descent module
novitskiy will be returning to earth
with paracelled
and with chapenko on october 17th for a
parachute assisted landing on the step
of kazakhstan
shkaplerov remains on board the
international space station ultimately
becoming station commander and he will
return to earth in late march with vanda
high and dubrov
who will have
racked up
some 355 days in space at the completion
of their mission
your head don't rotate a certain pelvis
hey megan
today just wanted to let you know that
uh the uh
the t2 uh
uh inspection or t2 kind of exercise
under supervision we're gonna shoot to
do that at 1700 after the safety
briefing so you can plan your day around
that
i copy after the uh
after the safety briefing got it thank
you very much
all right enjoy the uh
enjoy the hatch opening
and one question for you while we're
chatting real quick is the node 3
camcorder setup indicated it should be
on internal so recording audio is that
the intent
a firm it will be recording the uh the
audio but in private
[Music]
okay copy that thanks
what's up
foreign
uh
um
[Music]
1732.
the pressure is seven five fourteen
everything will be fine
foreign
you remove one
uh
there are some marks or labeling made
with cell pen
huh
foreign
17 30
is the time
when you put it on
17 30.
i will ask moscow moscow astray
i'm now on the paper version of the odf
so could you please
tell me which page has information
regarding the drive space dude
thank you standing by
[Music]
page 39 step 5.2
thank you
[Music]
standing by
for the 20-minute reading from you
this is mission control houston if
you're just joining us we're continuing
to follow along as the
crew on board the soyuz ms-19 veteran
cosmonaut anton shkaplerov
veteran russian actress julia parisieild
and her veteran
russian producer director clint shipenko
they arrived at the international space
station over two hours ago
at 7 22 a.m central time 8 22 a.m
eastern time for a docking to the
rassvet module
they
are in the process of
wrapping up leak checks
on their side of the docking interface
to rassvia
and that will set the stage for the
opening of the hatch and the greeting by
the expedition 65 crew along with a
welcoming ceremony
that will culminate their journey that
began with their launch
at 3 55 a.m central time this morning 4
55 eastern
aboard the
soyuz ms-19 spacecraft from the baikonur
cosmodrome in kazakhstan
parishild and shipenko
will begin 12 days of movie making for
their movie called challenge
on board the international space station
a movie set around paris hill portraying
a surgeon who was launched to the space
station to conduct an emergency
procedure on an ailing crew member
a crew member will be portrayed in the
movie
by russian cosmonaut oleg novitskiy of
the expedition 65 crew
is now 7-6-0
display the uh pressure on the station
is 7 12.
you know the crew
using mv on aboard this station reported
that the pressure was 760. so we will
use this data all right coty 760. and
once again
please download
standing by
uh what step you're at right now seven
nine three no seven nine
two
i told you to use uh to work
step seven nine three copy
so
i did not
hear you quite clearly um sorry so
i am using uh the pressure reported by
the crew 760. so i am sending us five
copy
[Music]
well we're basically
ready
and a good view of oleg novitskiy and
the
passageway the vestibule if you will
at the rassvet module
and we are getting close to that hatch
opening
as uh the pressure appears now to be
equalized uh between uh
rossviet and the soyuz ms-19 you're
looking at the hatch behind which are
the three new inhabitants of the
international space station
so we're going to uh broadcast it on the
big screen though okay got it
so we are now standing by for hatch
opening
okay it's good that we don't speak yet
[Music]
copy your game you go to open hatch
so we can actually we can um activate
the cameras because the
batteries were low and we were waiting
until the very last minute as you told
us okay uh go ahead guys
not the only producer director
at the international space station uh
quite a bit of uh documentation being
taken on the station side
oleg novitskiy uh in the field of view
right at the hatchway
as the ms-19 the soyuz crew itself
shkaplerov parishild and chapenko
begin work to open up the hatch on their
side of the docking interface
usually a flight engineer uh
does that does this part of
this action so but i have to do it all
we are good everything is good
the camera is on
we are ready to open the hatch
you can go ahead and open the hatch
uh the soyuz side hatch is still open
it's still closed
okay so we're going to open the hatch
and then we're going to exit the
view okay yes that is correct and then
the guys are going to open the hatch
from their side and then they're going
to flow towards the camera correct so we
need to stay out of the picture
in that case yes that is correct
okay sounds good
oleg novitskiy now about to rotate the
hatch handle
that will lead to the opening of the
hatch on the rossv outside of the
docking interface
the station crew who is opening the
hatch on their side
the uh rossviet hatch is open standing
by for the opening of the soyuz hatch
moscow
so the block actions on the page
these valves are
being opened so covered there
it's been opened
it is open now
is used for pressure equalization
for
two minutes
uh
s5
correction s3 is eliminated so we're
standing by for two minutes and then i
will close
one more step in the process to equalize
pressure across that hatch interface
and then uh anton shkaplerov will open
up the hatch
and the soyuz ms-19 crew will begin to
make their way inside the international
space station
[Music]
monitor the pressure realization uh well
it will be equalized when it will be uh
constant for two minutes
okay now it is 8 10
because on our side it is a little bit
higher because they have 760 which is
ideal for habitation
alex peter on spacex round two for your
information uh the
uh guys from the studies are still
working on equalizing pressure
[Music]
yes
my number in the cosmonaut core is 111
and yours can be
calculated if
we know what number peter twitter has
it's a good question
[Music]
me
habits
oh
russian cosmonaut piotr dubrov with the
video camera
at the ready
standing by for the final seconds here
of pressure equalization across the
hatchway
before anton shkaplerov opens up that
hatch
to complete today's process of arrival
at the international space station
allowing himself yulia parisild the
russian actress and her producer
director klim shipenko to enter the
complex where they will spend the next
12 days moviemaking i think the battery
is going to
go out again
all right it just shuts down
when the battery goes
okay i will i will check how much longer
um it will take to open the hatch maybe
you can just turn off the camera for the
time being
well you see it takes about two minutes
for the camera to
really activate this
okay
after the pressure realization and after
the osu
cover openings let's go to page 72.
we can turn it off for now um
it will take another
five minutes right now okay
seven five copy
corrections page seven to two before you
transition to the station
you will have to perform the actions at
the bottom of the page put the
cap
the activation uh you will have to do it
after you're done with the previous
action
so you will have to install the tab
you must go like this
that it should be tapped
unfortunately i wouldn't need this
[Music]
in floating in and then the flashes are
going to uh be going on
okay now i understand
remember so if you set up high uh
uh for the camera then you can do away
then once again
you see we didn't take it i'm confused
all right camera
for the camera
the height all right and we'll do the
transition let's only after that with
the okay let's have the guys not to
use the flash okay uh we'll try to do
that all right thank you very much again
now we will equalize the pressure
up to 760 then
the patch will be open
then we will enter this station one by
one
and then
so
should we go to sam for the press
conference
before
you
fully open this
h cover you will have to perform all
actions at the bottom of the page
put the tab on the activate embeds com
assets and after that you will
transition to the station
what about com assets
only after that only after that
assets should be deactivated
no actually the
by home assets we understand it's
embarrassed only
well you know i'm um
confused even more now
okay so letters
try uh to
figure it out so the camera is so cap
first
it is in the container number seven and
i have located it already this gap
foreign okay
so it has thread here
i will be able to install it only after
this edge is open correct
yes that's
[Music]
there are two options here
actually
you can open this edge transition to the
station but then go back
and please don't forget after that
perform all the actions at the bottom of
the page
and then you can go back to the station
all right
so could you please tell me uh how we do
this procedure on this station so the
video conference will be from a service
module
yes you will have a conference from
service module and after the conference
i can go back and
ask you again
uh you know so that you remind me of all
the action so that i don't forget the
order
okay this all tab should be in container
number seven all right container number
seven
[Music]
yes i have located it so
could you please give the
reading
the pressure
it's 762 on mv
copy 762.
[Music]
now
the actions
opening sounds good in work
okay so the tool
is inserted and
about six of seven
rotations are performed
uh
the camera is on
copy the crew members of the soyuz are
opening the hatch
and with the uh leak checks and the
pressurization checks and now having uh
been successfully completed uh we're
standing by for the opening of the hatch
by the soyuz crew it should swing open
momentarily
okay so release until hot stop and then
turn
along the arrow
you know leave the phone there so
they will be filming this whole
ceremony
okay yes well leaving them here for a
while
and the soyuz hatch now open at 10 a.m
central time 11 a.m eastern time
as the international space station flew
260 miles over the atlantic ocean
okay one by one
take turns
uh
and we are
translating into this station how happy
we caught it all
yes
oh
first in soyuz commander anton
shkaplerov
[Music]
russian actress yulia parisild
and her producer director klim shipenko
ten people on board the international
space station now as the crew makes its
way into the zvezda service module
for a welcoming ceremony
so a little more than six hours after
they launched from the baikonur
cosmodrome in kazakhstan the soyuz ms-19
crew is now on board the international
space station
cameras now will be set up in the zvezda
service module for the welcoming
ceremony
you can activate the sm camera
mcc moscow iss and space
you can activate the camera from
the service module and we're going to
perform the pio event on special round
one copy i'm going to translate to you
and the view now inside the zvezda
service module
the soyuz ms crew in the foreground
yulia parisild in the red flight suit
anton shkaplerov in the center front
front and center
and uh klim chapenko
from space to ground one go ahead and
space around one
so i'm going to give them all headsets
okay guys i see you very well
congratulations
on
the arrival and i'm going to give
the mic to
the balcony
go ahead and space to ground one
i read you out and clear
hello
we are ready the is desk crew members
are ready for the conference
we're going to give the mic to the
balcony
yes we can copy
hi everybody
congratulations
to the entire ms-19 crew and personally
you as a crew commander with on the
successful arrival on board the
international space station and the
beginning of your
globally important
mission
i wish
you to achieve all the goals of this
mission and of course
happy and safe return and most of all
please stay healthy
and i congratulate the isis crew on the
arrival of new editions
thank you
[Music]
with our backup crew the entire backup
crew
greets you on board the space station as
a member of
increment 65 lisa
and everybody
i love you all
we made it here and galena hi
the entire fund and all our colleagues
we all couldn't work we everything was
paralyzed except for watching your
arrival to the station but anyway
everything is nominal on the ground too
we're doing well we are so proud of you
all please have successful mission hugs
kisses
and lots and lots of images so beautiful
and so gorgeous
[Applause]
[Music]
your cd
as together with you it was extremely
emotional for everyone from sadness to
happiness
and i'm used to the fact that
we usually have some distance between us
but now it's space and earth that's
really impressive
julia will love you we'll love your
entire team
we are very proud of you now i know
uh what to wish to the cosmonauts
everything should go nominal that's our
best wish
and we want all your dreams to come true
and we'll be waiting for you back here
on earth
i love you all and my
best wishes and regards to my beloved
city of scotland
[Music]
and this is channel one
from mission control moscow we are
following the ambition
of course we were knocking on wood
together with everybody else
congratulations on your successful
arrival on orbit we have very little
time
we want to thank mcc moscow for this
opportunity please
share some of your feelings and
impressions
what happened how
what did you experience over those three
and a half hours how did you manage if i
may ask and what are your nearest plans
[Music]
everything was new to us today
every 30 seconds brought something
entirely new
and we just met the rest of the crew
uh the cosmonauts and astronauts who've
been living on board the station for
some time now but i'm still
in a dream i still feel that it's all
just the dream and i'm asleep yes it is
almost impossible to believe that this
actually all came to reality i also feel
like i'm still dreaming
it was incredible it was hard but
it was great to arrive on
on board the station
we were met
by friends and now we'll
have to learn
what to do next now so that
our
feelings
actually five minutes ago we floated in
so
there isn't much i can say
but
i actually love this fastest
arrival it was actually
quite fast well we had
a small delay
but thank you mcc moscow the team and
alexis celebio thank you
who
uh
taught us how to
make decisions on our own everything
went just fine we managed and now we are
looking forward to our work on orbeez
no how do you think your
guys managed
that was their first challenge
could you please repeat the question
[Music]
that was julius and clem's first
challenge
how did they manage
exactly as it was supposed to be
they helped
they knew what to do
they were using tablets
and they were aware of the situation so
everything
was done exactly the way it was required
by their training so they did a great
job okay thank you
and one more thing
[Music]
[Applause]
regards from your family of course
tanya and your daughters
they
[Music]
could not
be uh available for this video
conference but now they're led by kenor
and also your classmates sending their
hellos and their support
thank you andrei
thank you and i'll talk to you soon
this concludes our video conference
one more time congratulations on your
successful arrival and thank you all the
entire iss chrome member for arranging
for this video conference now guys enjoy
yourselves have some rest
this is mission control houston
the orbital outpost turns into a
high-flying movie set for the next 12
days
as yulia parisild klim shipenko
anton shkaplerov now on board the
the complex
receiving uh some initial uh briefing uh
words from oleg novitskiy the russian
cosmonaut as they look at their timeline
for upcoming activities that will
include a routine safety briefing
that is standard staple operations for
all
new arrivals on board the international
space station
in the uh congratulatory calls uh there
was one uh four parasite
from valentina tereshkova from
the russian mission control center
tereshkova the first woman to fly in
space
back in nineteen sixty three
parisild and shipenko will spend the
next 12 days filming uh elements of a
movie called challenge
in which she portrays a surgeon flown to
the space station to perform
an emergency procedure on an ailing crew
member that will be portrayed in the
movie by oleg novitskiy the russian
cosmonaut who they will return to earth
with
aboard the soyuz ms-18
on october 17th kazakhstan time
for a parachute assisted landing on the
step
of that country
so to recap the launch of
russian actress julia parisild her
producer director clint schapenko and
veteran russian cosmonaut anton
shkaplerov occurred at
3 55 a.m central time 4 55 a.m eastern
time
the soyuz ms-19 reaching orbit less than
nine minutes later
on a two-orbit rendezvous that resulted
in a docking to the rassvet module
of the international space station at 7
22 a.m central 8 22 a.m eastern time
after working leak checks and the
equalization of pressure across the
docking interface the hatch to the soyuz
spacecraft opened at 10 am central
11 am eastern time and you just saw the
welcoming ceremony where they received
congratulatory calls from officials and
dignitaries at the russian mission
control center in kariov
outside of moscow
so with that let's close our coverage
for today with a couple of programming
notes
next up one of the big ticket items will
be
the spacex crew dragon launch for crew 3
to the international space station with
that launch date set for october 30th
the crew 3 crew nasa astronauts raja
chari the crew dragon commander
the pilot tom marshburn matthias moorer
of the european space agency and nasa
astronaut kayla barron
there will be a mission overview news
conference here at the johnson space
center tomorrow
at 12 noon eastern time 1pm
12 noon central time 1 pm eastern time
on nasa television
the following day on thursday october
7th the four crew members will conduct a
news conference
here at the johnson space center at 1 pm
central 2 pm eastern time to talk about
their upcoming launch from the kennedy
space center again scheduled for october
30th so you'll want to tune in for the
mission overview briefing tomorrow and
the crew news conference
on thursday
with that we'll wrap up our coverage we
appreciate your time and attention today
and thanks for joining us
three new crew members on board the
international space station including a
russian actress and her producer
director
as the international space station plays
host to the filming of a movie called
challenge for the next 12 days
with that we'll close our coverage
thanks for watching throughout the
course of the morning this is mission
control houston
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
you